هذا المعرض الخاص بالمصاحف النادره
والنفيسه التي تبدا من القرن الاول للهجره
مكتوبه على الريق قبل صناعه الورق وما
تلاه من العصور بايدي كبار الخطاطين في
العراق وفي غير العراق هذه المخطوطات هي
جزء مما تضمه خزانه دار المخطوطات التي
يصل عدد المخطوطات فيها الى 47 الف مخطوطه
متعدده اللغات والموضوعات وهي تمثل كنزا
تراثيا حضاريا في العراق في حاضنه بغداد
منذ اكثر من الف عام ام هناك مخطوطات تمثل
نسخا نسميها النسخه اليتيمه هي النسخه
الوحيده وهناك نسخ مكتوبه بايدي المؤلفين
وهناك نسخ قديمه وتطالعون الان معنا
مجموعه من هذه الصحف التي كتب عليها
القران الكريم بالكتابه الكوفيه قبل ان
يكون هناك التنقيط
فرصه
نادره في النقطه اللي على مثل هذا النوع
من المخطوطات التي
لا مثيل لها في الدول
وتعرض لاول مره لتعبر عن تاريخ الخط
العربي وتاريخ العنايه بالقران الكريم
والمصحف الكريم وكيفيات الكتابه وجماليات
الكتابه والتنوع في كتابته عبر مدارس
متعدده في عدد من البلدان